so here's the thing I was reading the
other day about a mmm I don't say that a
person who gives financial advice that
everyone listens to not me okay and that
person said that they invest differently
because they have twenty million dollars
or whatever it was I don't remember
there's a lot of money and they invest
differently than the advice that they
give and I just thought you know that's
a little troubling to me so I do the
stuff we teach I don't own the credit
card I do live on a budget you can ask
my wife to look at her little envelope
system and it's got some money in it and
she actually uses it to buy stuff we
have a very unusually good life because
we make a lot of money now but we've
been broke I only have investments in
two things real estate that I pay cash
for which is what I tell you to do and
mutual funds I don't own any single
stocks I don't have any little super
double backflip secrets of the rich
investments because my net worth is
hundreds of millions of dollars and so I
have to do it differently
I don't do it differently I dance with
the girl that brought me the principles
that got me here are the ones that are
gonna keep me going and it's what I've
taught my kids to do and as soon as my
grandkids are just a little bit older
they're gonna be teaching them today the
same thing because this is how you screw
it up is if you think you're different
because you got a little money the
principles that got you there will get
you there
and so we still live debt-free we still
live on a budget and we still invest in
the four types of growth stock mutual
funds and that's really what we do and
it's just devastatingly simple and
predictable and consistent
and I don't have anything I do secretly
that's different the only advantage I
have is over over a lot of my listeners
I make more money and so um I mean my
income these days is ridiculous
but I own a company that generates 200
million dollars a year of course my
incomes ridiculous so it that part's
different right and so the percentages
that we put on stuff or it doesn't take
but a tiny percentage of our income to
live a very good life and so our
generosity is outrageous and our
investing is outrageous because we just
don't need the money
for anything else and so that's the only
thing that's really different about me
but I don't I don't invest differently
than I tell you to invest I don't say
well you know now that I've reached this
level I have a double secret Amex black
card or whatever it is I don't I've just
got debit cards and honestly sometimes
with the ID theft the way it is I think
I'd go through a new debit card about
every 90 days these stinking banks man
they cannot keep it's just ridiculous
there are algorithms for ID theft just
blows up everything I'm constantly
having to enter a new debit card number
and all my apps and stuff but I'm just
like you the same way same thing I don't
have any special anything on that it's
all the same so that's what you're
looking for if you sit down with a real
estate agent and they say you know well
III you know I don't have a 15 year
mortgage I I don't believe in those I
believe in are just able rate mortgages
but you should get one I know if I'm
dealing with a smart person here I don't
know if I wanted to help me with my
house and so I want people out me out
well aligned with people that I'm
aligned with and that's what you're
looking for Laura in this situation when
you sit down with these smart mister
pros it needs to not feel slimy I mean
when you get home you don't need to feel
like you need to take a shower you know
you're meet with somebody and have that
feeling like this it's like Ghostbusters
I just got slimed you know
yeah and you can't live your life that
way so sit down with somebody that you
have the sense that everything down
inside of you is okay my wife is from
the hills of East Tennessee and when she
runs into a bad one she says she has a
bad feeling and it's a seven syllable
word feeling and those feelings are
deadly freakin accurate go with them go
with them if you meet with someone for
an investment or a real estate or you're
working on your wills and you just feel
weird
there's a reason cuz there's weird crap
in the air when something's weird just
know there's a reason it's cuz it's
weird you don't have to put up with that
there's another one of those I fired a
lawyer a while back because he said well
I'm a lawyer not to listen I don't give
a crap what you are your job here's you
work for means I'm one right in the
dadgum checks and I'm fired not on staff
while you're I don't mean that I mean an
outside guy but a nice unbelievable so
you got it you got a not to have
weirdness in the air this is the Dave
Ramsey show